there's nothing complicated about making
a compost heap this one is just a pile
with materials almost randomly added to
not need to use a bin which can buy
cheaply from your council well just get
held some pallets and time together with
bayless wine you should aim to a green
materials which tend to be wet like
grass cuttings fresh weeds root veg
feelings in rub equal proportions to
brown materials which absorb much of the
liquids and they dare and structure to
the heat so things like old plant stems
edge brooding spark or wood chippings
and cardboard and scrunched up paper
they're all good
inside the heat there is a virtual
explosion of microscopic life mostly
bacteria and fungi here we can see the
threads of the fungi which get to work
on the audio material and also tracked
you by the video material of wood lice
but generally speaking if you get too
many would license mohib it's too dry so
water it well and it'll compost much
better the compass really starts to heat
up and you can even see steam rising up
and get it hot it up but how have you
make it compost is wonderful stuff makes
your flowers grow makes your vegetables
grow it's good for all the garden so get
composting now